juarez
a foul goal line goalie soccer ball fair
play fair fair play
who uses the term fair play who wants to
watch a sport that's played fairly i
like that yeah you're really getting
into this thank you i don't want to go
back to work hi i'm spencer and today
we're here to try something we've never
done before which is speaking welsh
inspired by fx's welcome to ruxome
starring ryan reynolds and rob
who are also teaming up to do something
they've never tried before
just purchasing a football team that's
soccer in america
but they're doing it in wales even
though they know nothing about football
or owning a team or working together or
speaking welsh but i'm sure it'll be
fine because that's the american way
well ryan's canadian
[Music]
from hollywood to wales the donkey
series tracks ryan reynolds and rob
mcelhenny's crash course and football
club ownership in the interwoven fates
of a team in a blue collar town
all right we're gonna start with some
english phrases you only hear in wales
mitching mitching mitching
playing playing it's complaining you're
mitching like that was a mitch in party
does this mean hungry goofing off
goofing off
okay
chop sing chop sing i think is like like
singing is chopsing eating is chopsing
chopping it up mouthing off i'm so good
at this y'all at home they'd say you're
busting they're busting your chops
chop saying like i feel like there's a
connection there daps i think that means
like a high five like that
did that
that's a dab oh [ __ ]
daps yeah i don't know sneakers i would
never have gotten that is that titty
tidy
listen we don't know how to pronounce
anything we're just we're just reading
things yo bro check it out that guy is
mighty tighty like if you're watching
soccer and someone scores a goal you're
like that goal was tidy i like that now
we're gonna move on to greetings which
are actually in welsh
that means so it's a greeting we're
still in the greetings
it does saying who are you what's going
on what's going on what's up
how are you
nice
hui le metro
catch you later
have a good day i'll see you later
that's what oh oh my gosh i got one
have a good day have a good day because
he's saying it like good night goodbye
goodbye that was close same thing so now
we're gonna try our hands at some common
welsh words
coach coach i think of like scotch coach
and soda yeah or like football coach
like cool
groovy
a hug or warm embrace oh a couch
[Music]
wasted drunk a drink
you want to get a beer
i'm getting a cool right after this
that's pretty good
this doesn't sound that pleasant gross
it's gross
wow yes
reminds me of like oogie boogie sounds
like bubble gum maybe it's like chit
chat it's so intense man brother yeah
yeah
you killed my igamu gum
oh it's a place is it england holy head
cardiff capital city of wales listen we
just learned one more thing ryan rob
here you go
the capital of wales is cardiff or
cair death
now we're going to try some football
terms and reminder football means soccer
goal
go
[Music]
what wrexham afc will be world champions
team is team okay
is gonna be champion wrexham afc will be
a team income purpose defense
[Music]
exactly i want you to try and say this
phrase
in
welsh we could barely do one word and
you want us to say a whole phrase
welcome to wrexham rfx
aya drexel
welcome to wrexham
[Music]
welcome to wrexham
rfx to the people of wales i am so sorry
that we butchered your language but
hopefully ryan reynolds and rob
mcelhenny can bring a championship to
wrexham afc
be sure to watch fx's welcome to rexum
airing on wednesdays on fx and streaming
on hulu